what would you like a rap about
suggestion number one
socks
socks lovely cool
what type of socks do you enjoy most
cotton cotton very specific i was like
you know the high socks the ankle socks
so you were like no i'm going for the
fabric cotton socks
we um we had a cat that was called socks
and we call it socks because we had two
but lost one in the washing machine
that's nice
it's not that's not why this book
yeah good cool just i just want to check
it it sounds like a you know
[ __ ] far right organization
people in the middle excluding
lincolnshire which like wreck
alpine skiing alpine skiing thank you
for clarifying as well
alpine skiing range rovers cotton socks
people in this corner watching right now
edinburgh lovely
[ __ ] lovely accent i love the
edinburgh accent i will do that section
of the rapper in the edinburgh accent my
wife
proposed got married in vanessa
cathedral was too fancy for us i
apologize
you guys were like
isn't scotland the same as england no
don't tell him that he won't murder you
people people over here what you're
right
okay you said kanye west what did you
say
imperialism
[Applause]
people really enjoy non-metric
measurement systems i guess
kanye west and imperialism
cotton socks um
range rover and the other one that we
got was
alpine skiing
um you should hold on to your
suggestions we're going to come to you
in the middle of the wrap for it what
i'll do is i'm going to thrust the
microphone in your face and you'll tell
me the suggestion that will carry on
just because usually i only take five
suggestions we've got six and i'm
worried if i get it from now off again
so
let's um let's let's get this all set up
this is this is how the show
uh is going it's gonna be a freestyle
rap to end it uh i'm excited and i want
you guys to not worry because it will
not be anywhere near as atrociously
toe-curlingly embarrassingly bad as you
are expecting a privately educated
middle-class white british boy
[Music]
it's gonna be
good i know i'm convinced i just don't
think you guys are
automobiles in the wrap strange to go
there rappers on the dashboard in the
range rover not the land rover
understand y'all
[Music]
on the country roads there in the muddy
groves in my range rover i'll be hanging
with the youths in the back like a
soccer mommy an suv yeah i got much
money and i put it in the garage off to
the garden i'm looking around i'm
feeling like i'm starving i wanna do
something up high altitude why cause i'm
a fly guy and so i supply myself with
the bitter skis going off to austria i'm
traveling with leaves it's such a short
hop when i'm there from heathrow i'm on
the top of this
there on the chairlift then look at me
say chris put the skiing in your rap i
say yeah afraid ski with some nice
little schnapps in the glass
[Applause]
[Music]
it used to be amazing don't stop and
think 150 years ago the whole map was
pink that was the color of england the
british empire i know kanye west might
really aspire to be imperial with his
rats from the speakers he's trying to
get control by releasing sneakers and
divorcing kim kardashian will they ever
be friends again who's even saying it'd
be so hard to say this one for sure it's
cold up there when you're in edinburgh
you should all know a real fun
that's the only castle that's never been
invaded in scotland it's got a very
large cliff if you try and walk up and
enter it they're like aywee buddy you
should be finished we're gonna stab you
in the face why because you're english
we don't like them you're gonna grab
this if you're there maybe get some deep
fried haggis or a deep fried mars bar
ever so pretty genuinely if there please
go to the city chippy it's incredible
they got the nice salt and sauce maybe
get some iron brew i'd be getting on the
horse not a heroin joke not a problem
for you i'm just staying there wearing
my riding shoes i need to make sure that
i got my crop and got some clothes
fitting things that right at the top
call them socks people say chris have
you forgotten of the fabric of the socks
i'm like no they're made of cotton it's
incredible it just whips away the
moisture do you want some man-made
fabrics got a choice to i'm like no i
tried once to get some [ __ ] socks they
were made of nylon and with their
though it has a problematic history in
your country
[Music]
we all heard that we're like while we're
waiting could it be better shouting out
golf balls with the texture of your
sweater if you can't see it i'll make it
really simple cause just like your
sweater golf balls are white and dimpled
[Applause]